all right guys so one of the best parts
about living in london is that i can
take a two-hour train ride to anywhere
but here is the issue with that this
gives me the opportunity to just
randomly go anywhere in europe
throughout the week now don't get me
wrong this is a great great option right
but anyways it's a random tuesday and i
am going to paris yep i stayed all night
didn't sleep my bags are packed and i'm
ready to go
[Applause]
right
[Music]
this is the perfect level
the coffee
is um
i'm american it needs more sugar
[Music]
they give you mayo with your fries here
mayo
all right guys look at where we're
staying
look at this cute ass kitchen
and then we got this bedroom
and then look roomies
can go right into the bedroom over here
look it
and then
and then look at this nice mirror for
selfies
how cute would it be to live in this
apartment i'm about to move in they've
not about to have me move out
then we got this cute little window
i wonder if this would be monthly
i know huh it's probably expensive it's
gotta be
and then to the next floor we go
[Music]
i gotta make a tick tock about this this
is gonna go viral
[Music]
and then
this is the view from upstairs
how cute is that
[Music]
it's going to be so cute
so get all the footage
look at this is the view out here
i'm in paris [ __ ]
the lady made eye contact with me
how many hours of sleep are you on ten
minutes actually yeah i think i'm on
maybe two you're like one and a half one
and a half and a half solid we're ready
we are ready
all right show me the fit show me the
fit on
paris
super cute
[Music]
can anyone tell us what this is
uncultured swine yeah yeah it's cool we
just i don't know what we're looking at
[Music]
has been dreaming about this since she
was a kid how are you feeling um a
little emotional
she her as as a kid her room was like
like what did you say paris these when i
was um when i was little my room was
paris because i might come here so it's
kind of like i don't know like i know it
seems like something
small but since i was a kid it's just
always been a dream so kind of surreal
moment
all right guys look at the lion dick
imagine being the person that created
that carp
wow
hey
gabby have you ever been in an eiffel
tower
all right guys this is italian food here
i don't understand why the bread here is
so good like it's so good it's so much
better than normal bread
hear that crunch oh my god
why aren't you afraid of me
why why can't i get this close to you
i don't like i don't understand
[Music]
you are so cute
i kind of want one
okay so we're out tonight
in epic fail yeah it hasn't gone well
as usual
we waited too long
shocked
not really
expected
exactly now
did i almost get hit by a car
maybe what paris
looks like right now all the bars are
like kind of close
so
it's not like it would be but
this is what i think we're like more
downtown here
[Music]
sorry guys the steadiness is not working
[Music]
as i said earlier european girls really
be wearing clothes out here
yeah like
they they go out to bars here the girls
and they actually cover up
they're not half naked
they're not
i look at them and i'm like
oh it's get cold here
shut the [ __ ]
but today
i'm treating myself it's called treat
yourself
yes please
very nice
and this is the oh i just want to trim
jeremy i have um a lot of dead ends so i
just want the dead ends off then blow
dry yeah
yeah straight yes
how long have you been cutting hair for
sorry how long have you cut hair here
i don't understand
how many years have you cut hair
22 years wow
you don't look that old
[Music]
which one's the best
everything is best i think every well it
can't all be the best gabby just spent
35 dollars in back rooms these better be
the best macaroons
yeah we didn't think it
five for 12.
five euros look how close these freaking
birds are
i'm like aren't you why aren't you
afraid of me
i think our coach is not happy that
we're missing practice tomorrow
so it's going to be really fun to tell
we're going to miss saturday
the eiffel tower from under it
look how gross that is
oh
[Music]
[Music]
that looks so good
and look at my handsome waiter
i'm giving the sugar baby yeah that's
okay i'm ready
hi
hello hi
yeah you have the menu okay okay it is
what should i get is it wrong to get
pizza
look at this
[Music]
tonight tonight we're going to a karaoke
bar and if we're not thinking love sosa
i don't want it i don't want it i'm
gonna turn you easy out
this is the elevator
oh my god imagine if we got stuck in
this
it's okay
give me up give me up give me okay it's
good
um
i was trying to go for sugar baby vibes
it's giving what it's supposed to do
the girls that get it get it and the
girls that don't don't
okay guys i don't really know why this
is special but it's cool looking
okay what's prettier me
or the palace
so i put a selfie up i'm not even gonna
lie i just wanted to see if this guy
would view it
on my story i viewed it i was the first
one
it's all [ __ ]
i'm tired of this
look it's a minute can i take a video of
you making the coffee
look it he's
it's a little cart guys
have you been to the us before
yeah
the coffee there is sweeter yeah
it's a little california
chicago
this is good lighting
what's the best thing to see
in france
what what's the best like place to visit
in france is this it yeah yes
this is ooh that looks good cafe latte
car
look at that
[Music]
love my life
let me see show me the lock
[Music]
oh you haven't written it yet show me it
after you wrote it
tj plus gabby
and our anniversary is the 14th of
november
[Music]
oh [ __ ] you are crying
[Music]
oh
is there anything you want to say to tj
i love you [ __ ] i'm going to stop
loving you [ __ ]
all by myself
i'm still all by myself
[Music]
i miss you one day
i'm just playing don't go watch my
[Music]
vlogs you know what you know this [ __ ]
just asked me she said do you want
gelato
of course i want gelato like why is that
even a question
um i know i said that i was trying to
lose weight this year
shoot okay
i know i said i was trying to lose
weight this year never did i ever say
successfully
what do you all be on in france
i don't
we do not do this in the u.s
[Music]
oh
[Music]